we're talking about shifts and
reflections and now I think about in
horizontal terms okay so first if I want
to move horizontally want to move
horizontally
what do I have to do to the X how do i
modify the plane alright I'm going to
add or subtract a cluster of subtractive
cluster okay so what does this look like
right we know if I say X plus a for
instance right which way is that going
to move
plus a remember this is shifting thing
is a little bit confusing it's going to
go to the left okay it's going to go to
the left a units be correspondingly if I
say X minus a that's going to go to the
right
I was missing I'm missing a boy
we'll get to that in a second now if I
want to do rather than a shift of just
moving sliding translating in that way
if I want to reflect right the whole
idea of reflection this is where we
first met
integers right it's this idea of
different directions that numbers can go
at you okay so only to do again with the
X is we're going to how would you
actually say it rather than add or
subtract we're going to what do we do to
the X what we actually do when
multiplying by negative 1 negative 1 is
what turns us around right multiply
that's what's going to give us a flip
now justice it's less important that's
why okay but you might as well keep it
in the same category if you instead of
shifty or reflecting you want to stretch
out it's almost like a combination of
the previous two right because you're
going to multiply again right but if you
don't multiply by a negative number if
you multiply by some positive constant
right now the great thing about
understanding this horizontally and
laying in that in this way is because
once you understand that doing a very
quick is really much the same thing
except instead of thinking about X's
because that's horizontal you're gonna
think about why is because that's very
cool right so again you're gonna add or
subtract a constant where you're gonna
have like Y plus a I can now be careful
right just like with the X's the plus or
minus is a kind of backwards aren't they
so I have y plus a which ways I could've
go
which way is it going - so for instance
if I gave you this you know that's going
to move two units
- though it's going to move two units to
the right
okay now you're used to thinking of the
pluses you're used to seeing why is the
subject
so if you see y equals that plus 1y I go
up okay but what does that really mean
this plus one is not really modifying
this is it right it's actually it's
actually Y minus one that's what it's
really changing right which is why this
is backwards it goes to the right
this is backers as well right it goes up
just like this does it's the same
equation right so this actually is going
to go down and this is going to go up
okay
again you would just rephrase it in a
way that makes it clear to you whichever
one's more intuitive yes
he lives in one
okay hold on so I say multiply by
constant greater than zero in order to
have a stretch right because you've
multiplied one one that's less than zero
then you're going to have a reflection
right does that make sense yes I know
now then I went on and said depending on
whether you want to make it wider or
whether you want to compress it then you
will multiply by like a half or quarter
right or you would do by two or three so
yes exactly right
just like here how you've got either
this kind of reverse thing happening
okay if I say let's return back to you I
always find it quite hopeful parabolas
are really good shapes to take these
patterns let me just test out what
happens so if I consider this okay and I
replace my X with an ax okay so that's
going to be so pleased okay so as that
number increases that's going to become
steeper and steeper and steeper and
steeper and steeper right so that's
that's a compression factor right if
this number is B so again there's that
reverse then you make it bigger and it
gets now and if you make this smaller
like 1/2 or 1/4 or 1 over 100 it's going
to get shallower in chattering okay but
I keep both of those under the broad
category of stretching because like
while stretching this way and stretching
that way are really kind of the same
thing
what if modifying a scale gerenuks
confusing them with numbers that
original form is 1x and then they're
imagining one last question maybe I
could say stretch / compressed it's the
same oh yes it's just a different but
it's still it's still what I came sorry
where were we
let's finish off the patterns that we
can see again a reflection vertically
we'll be multiplying Y by my side
now you'll notice notice that in certain
cases in certain cases these are the
same surprises if we have a look at y
equals I squared if we say y equals
minus x squared
be careful what's being modified it sure
looks like X doesn't it right but it's
not really because let's think about
this right this is over here okay that's
one way of seeing it the other way of
seeing it is to actually modify X but
would be the whole X gets changed so I'm
going to swap out the X and that thing
is going to be squared okay so yeah hold
on a second but that's just x squared
why is that
because if I take if I take the parabola
right and I reflect it horizontally the
parabola becomes the parabola right like
it's the same shape even if it's not the
terminal it's the same shape even if its
flipped horizontally okay so these
horizontal fit no effect right you get
the same graph back but here right
you're really actually changing the Y
which is why you get the thing down Hey
so that's what that's doing okay one
more thing right if you have a linear
function you have a linear function like
say y equals x right if I put a minus
sign there which am i modified the X or
the Y yes that's exactly right because
here his ex right y equals x and here is
y equals minus X now has this blue graph
is it the vertically flipped version or
is it the horizontally flipped version
and the answer is yes right because
because if you flip it vertically boy if
you flip it horizontally you will get
the same thing so in this case it really
actually can be on both flipping
horizontally phonetic we got the same
thing right but in other cases it's look
okay let's just finish off you just
multiply by a it's exactly right now in
exactly the same way by the way in
exactly the same way if I think about y
equals say let's put it was from the
black for them again
is this a horizontal stretch or a
vertical stretch slash slash compression
which is it
well the answer is again again the
answer is yes and let me show you how it
is one or the other okay first let's
these here at the X because that looks
like it's where it is right this edge is
not being multiplied by four right the X
is actually being multiplied by two can
you see that so so here I'm going to get
this factor being that's that's the town
the X is actually changing okay but if I
want to think about in terms of Y I'm
going to put the four or here okay so
I'm either making this stretched out
vertically or I'm making this squashed
in horizontally but they're the same
thing right like if you take if you take
your original if we are to stretch it
out vertically it's gonna get it's gonna
get taller isn't it
right but if you squash it in
horizontally it's still gonna get pull
up right one narrow okay do the same
thing looked at from two different
perspectives